alexa it's show time and just like that
alexa dimmed the lights open netflix and
set my devices to do not disturb but
it's not just alexa google assistant can
also make your home smarter with
elaborate reactions using simple
commands amazon and google both call
these groupings of actions routines a
lot of people have smart light bulbs and
many others use smart speakers but these
two things don't really work together
unless you use something like routines
so what are routines and why would you
even want to set them up i'll break it
down
normally you use your voice to get your
smart devices to do what you want and
usually it's just one task at a time hey
google turn off my lights
[Music]
routines take that a step further by
allowing your tech to set off many tasks
with just one command you can set up
routine like actions on your smartphone
and use them to kickstart reactions on a
wide variety of devices those include
lights vacuums tvs even smart microwaves
compatible with amazon alexa or google
assistant your smart speakers can also
trigger routines when they pick up
certain sounds like running water or
they can be timed to go off at a certain
time of day like at sunrise routines are
an early attempt to give us those truly
smart homes we all imagine where our
houses anticipate what we want and
attempt to give it to us and they could
do that with little effort on our part
companies offer some preset routines for
example alexa's stock market update
fills you in on the market at sunset
google's home app has a routine that you
can add to your morning regime it can
help you get out of the house on time by
reminding you how much time you have
left before you're running late now
let's check out some routines
number one leaving your home
alexa i'm leaving
[Music]
you don't have to manually turn off the
lights when you're leaving for the day
if you set up a leaving routine you can
set up this routine to lock your door
activate your security system it can
even listen out for like broken glass
all useful stuff both amazon and google
products will let you set up leaving
routines and you can set up whatever
alert word you want and if you want to
make it look like you're at home when
you're not you can set up a routine for
going on vacation that way you can have
your lights turn on during certain times
of the day and make it look like
someone's home
number two intruder alert
now watch this
alexa intruder alert
[Music]
this is a pretty neat party trick that
doubles as an extra security measure
this routine can turn on the lights play
doomsday music or sirens basically
anything that would make burglars think
twice before entering your home again
you can set up these type of routines
with both google and amazon's smart home
apps we'll get into how to do this but
first one last routine
number three morning shower routine
[Music]
this is one of the featured routines on
the alexa app you can have alexa listen
out for running water or other sounds
like dogs barking and snoring and
similar to wake words the device detects
these sounds by identifying acoustic
patterns privacy wise amazon says the
sounds aren't stored or sent to the
cloud i set it so that when running
water is detected alexa will tell me the
weather and play my favorite playlist
but sometimes things go wrong if you're
running water in another room alexa
might think that you're about to take a
bath and inadvertently set off the
routine when you don't want it to avoid
this you can pick which speakers you
want constantly listening
now for the not so fun part setting
these things up it may take some
creativity and experimentation to get
things just right you'll want to make
sure that all the smart devices you use
are compatible with a single ecosystem
of products for instance you'll need to
buy everything that's compatible with
alexa if you're in the amazon ecosystem
but that won't always be the case a new
standard is rolling out later this year
that will make most new devices
compatible with all voice assistants if
alexa is your assistant of choice the
routine tab on the android and iphone
app will let you set up how you want to
trigger an alert you can do it with your
voice and if you add your calendar your
daily schedule you can trigger it with a
button on your smart speaker or with
sound detection and google's home app
lets you do this stuff too pick a time
of day or other category or you can
create a routine manually from scratch
you decide what actions you want
performed and when and once you're set
your gadgets should be able to run on
autopilot whenever your routines are
triggered
in the future as more devices come out
imagine adding a flying security camera
to that intruder alert routine or
getting a home robot to bring you
popcorn when you activate showtime i'd
like this setup process to get simpler
which could happen soon too that's part
of the idea behind mater a smart home
standard supported by google amazon and
others having an almost universal device
language could simplify how those
products are set up and how they
communicate with each other i'll have to
check that out once mata is released
later this year so subscribe so you know
when it's here and comment and let me
know what fun routines you've set up
until next time
[Music]